Okay. So let's talk about another type of queue
called pull queues. This queue solves another kind of
problem. Let's say that you implemented a site that
requires humans to review comments. So the users of the
site generate comments and these comments need to be
reviewed before they are published. Similarly to push queues, you
could create a queue. And then insert comments to
be reviewed into this queue as tasks. And external people,
well in our case robots, could review the comments, perhaps
working from home in their spare time. So you have
your queue where you add comments as review tasks. Then
the different people would pull a review task from the queue
and work on it. So let's look at the difference
with push queues. Well in this case, App Engine is
not executing the tasks. They are instead executed by the
external workers. You can say that the task is pulled from
the queue by the external worker. That's why they are
called pull queues. The tasks that are pulled from the
queue are leased by the external workers. The worker must
complete the task within the lease time in which case it
can be deleted. But if the task is not completed
within the lease time, it is automatically returned to the
queue. If we compare a pull queues to push queues,
the differences are. So pull queues do not have a URL,
since your code is not completing the task. Each
task is leased by a worker for a certain
amount of time. A worker must delete the task
when it's completed, otherwise it is returned when the
lease expires. External workers pull the queue using a
REST interface. And there is no default queue for
pull queues, so you need to explicitly create them.
That's it for pull queues. Let's have a quiz.